all right y'all all right y'all
all right damn it let's go let's go okay
here we go let's do it welcome back
Happy New Year
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome to River with Griffin y'all
2022 Edition happy New Year so excited
we're back at it again
so you know let's just get at this
yeah back at it again
with it with Griffin
2022 happy New Year
uh make sure you check me out daily on
Twitch I am at Eric Griffin gaming
always on Twitch why are we pretending
like bidet's work like here's what I
mean by that
I don't care what you say
I don't care how long you sit on that
thing with the water splashing on you
Hanukkah how long you do it for don't
think that you don't steal
have to do some cleanup okay that's all
I'm saying
like don't think like with this one you
can wash
and then turn the fan on
and then think you could just get up and
walk away
that ain't true man
and I'm at an age where the the cleanup
is usually longer than the delivery
like that right so this thing is
ridiculous man like
some I don't I'm trying not to be
graphic okay because you know what I
mean but like your what you Splash you
wash you sit there for a second and
sometimes and and let's be honest too I
mean it's more like sometimes I'm
sitting there like oh stop flirting with
me but day you know what I mean because
you know it'd be hitting you good and
you're like oh man what is this uh
sensation okay so other than that you
know you sit there I don't care for how
long you sit there maybe a minute how
long ever long you want to be doing it
but I don't care what you do when it's
time for the wipe it's like nothing
happened it's like the thing didn't do
nothing and you still end up doing the
same amount like they give you this lie
that like oh you're gonna be saving
toilet paper you're gonna be saving the
environment no you're not because now
you got to use this sucker to not only
clean but dry you have to dry off too
because you soaking wet with Booty Juice
okay and it's just I don't know I just
think like this is a sham like bidets
are a fraud okay unless you've got some
high-powered one that could take paint
off a a battleship and that's unless you
have one of those this sucker just I'm
just telling you it don't work properly
I'm just throwing that out there once
again thanks for subscribing thanks for
sharing and all you know all that stuff
uh you know I I appreciate that so
um 50 y'all can you believe it I know I
look delicious 50 years old Rachel got
me this great big beautiful 50 card but
you know birthdays are weird for dudes
man if we're just being honest right and
you get to a certain age where your
birthday is not even important anymore
even with my girl my my birthday is
supposed to be her birthday that's like
you know you know how they get when it's
like oh it's your birthday I have all
these plans for us and you're just like
well I I don't sound like something I
want to do on my birthday but it's like
you know it's
it's like when you're a dude your
birthday becomes your girl's birthday
and then her birthday is her birthday
you know what I mean so
it is what it is so look at this so like
people would buy tables at EDC okay so
they buy like a like a table while the
festival's going on right EDC Las Vegas
look at this receipt
[Applause]
764.50 let me say it again
look at this receipt y'all
[Music]
764.50 to sit at some table listening to
electric dance music
man are you kidding me
look at this receipt
I don't drink alcohol y'all
but let's just talk about the water
bucket
39 water bottles
2925 dollars what
what
the water to let me say it again
2925 for the water man
uh
look at the Red Bull bucket
16 Rebels
112 no I'm sorry
twelve hundred dollars
Red Bulls for 75 a can
what's happening so I don't even know
what this other stuff is like I don't
know what Ace of Spades brute is that it
needs to cost 23
000 or how about this class Azul
Reposado what is that chat can somebody
tell me what that is that costs 51
uh here's another receipt y'all just
another receipt for EDC Las Vegas right
and this one I can't I can't make it
bigger but this one is
519 and 39 cents y'all
um yeah you can't read this one as well
as the other one but I mean damn they
bought something that was a hundred
thousand dollars I mean I don't know
what this is is that tequila is it uh
what is the space T Bucket that cost 75
or the all are welcome what's all are
welcome for eleven thousand dollars
y'all PJ Rose mag what is that thirty
five hundred dollars and then uh good
for this the service charge was ten
thousand dollars uh okay so that's the
administration fee so they charged an
administration fee of ten thousand
dollars and then the service charge the
20 the disc go to the waiter did the
waiter are they splitting the tips
because the waiter got and I'm sure it
was some beautiful somebody you know
what I mean they got a business card
because this is bottle service for 24
000 I hope they got that tip more power
to you but damn y'all damn advice from a
grown ass man
I love this one because I was talking
about marriage so let's talk about this
one because this one is so important I
think
got married a month ago no kids were
allowed sister-in-law is still mad about
that well let me tell you something
we got a no kid's wedding going on too I
don't find any problem with this at all
you either have a kids allowed wedding
or not if you want to have an adult
wedding I have no problem with that I
think both ways are fine and I think
it's one of those things where you just
have to let them do people don't have
children they are oftentimes super
selfish about that they think that that
you know well I have a kid so my kid is
allowed to do go everywhere and do
everything because it's my kid and you
just have to deal with it nah sometimes
you know sometimes we don't want to deal
with your kid I didn't enjoy making your
kids so why do I have to deal with your
kid you know what I mean so I don't
think there's anything wrong with this
if you want to have a adults only
wedding uh you know you just have to
like bring you have to do that way ahead
of time you got to tell people with kids
ahead of time like babies and stuff like
little little toddlers like yeah we try
not to have toddlers at the wedding all
right we don't want baby crying during
the vows we don't want you to have to
sit there we want we also want the
people there to just enjoy being out
having an adult time without worrying
about oh we got to go change the diapers
and all this kind of stuff so it's for
you too so
in terms of this question I know that
your sister-in-law is still mad but she
probably mad too because her sister is
being taken over by some man but it is
what it is she'll get over it just kill
her with kindness and I'm telling you
she'll eventually get over that and good
luck all right but then here's like
freaking Jeremy Renner you know what I
mean who I'm kind of like it's like damn
you know what I mean hi
and like he was um
he was a 49ers fan okay which was great
because we were just going at it all
game so then like
he disappears for the first half because
he goes and he's in the owner's box with
the 49ers because he's a 49 he grew up
in the Bay Area he's been a 49ers fan
since the 80s he told me so he's like
you know he off doing that but it's not
good seats the owner's box is like way
up they looking at the game on TV but
I'm sure it's like Swanky whatever right
so this guy he comes back at halftime
and he been drinking you know what I
mean and he's just a fun like everybody
was just I don't drink so it is what it
is but I was eating the food and food
was delicious they had this Peruvian
chicken off the chain shout out to sofa
and that Peruvian chicken and then you
know so then he says to me he's like I
just want to get hammered and watch my
49ers win so we just going at it man and
he was just like I'm saying like just uh
like it's just weird experience to like
hear somebody so notable and that you
know you see him and you know him face
recognition especially if you're a
Marvel nerd and I'm just sitting here
chilling with him like I'm black widow
you know what I mean
you know what I'm saying and then like
you know he's like he's you know he's
he's Tipsy and he's like you know they
about to kick a field goal and he's all
like oh if I have my bow and arrow right
now I would just shoot that out
that he was like I would just take my
bow and arrow and I would just like you
know like if like if he was hot like if
he was really Hawkeye you know so that's
the kind of fun we were having they blew
their load on disneyweek that was the
best not just because the performances
happened to been great but like I want
to hear the Disney songs yeah I don't
need to hear and also no Shady Carrie
Underwood congrats on everything you do
I don't need a Carry Underwood theme oh
bro you know what a Carrie Underwood
theme is for Bar Mitzvah 100 not for the
last episode I couldn't tell you one
Carrie Underwood song yeah you could I
could
uh dug my keys into the side of it
and also I wouldn't have known Jesus
thanked me
oh that's her song yeah she's not bad
I'm not no shade but I'm just I wouldn't
have known but have you ever heard this
song
Can You Feel The Love yeah because
that's awesome I do I totally agree with
you and by the way too hey American Idol
contestants
sing the Disney songs we know
okay I knew most of them stop picking
the b-sides from the no from the crap
Disney movie no but you're talking about
like Moana and stuff that's just because
we're older those aren't our Disney
Generations maybe I really think that's
what it is no but sometimes I still feel
they don't even pick the lead track it's
like you might be right this is like oh
this is like this other track that I'm
gonna fool people with no no man when
Christian is saying circle of life I
watched it so many times that's like big
boy from last year I I re-watched that
too hey that dude was great he should
have won but I also understand because
you want to talk about singing and you
want to have that Idol thing hit didn't
have that but so I get it but now the
term Idol is changing to like involve
all body types oh exactly so we live in
a world right now where you go why then
are these other people losing
country I think is a big part of
American Idol a lot of the winners are
country and a lot many of the finalists
I don't know if I would say many of them
but we should actually look that up I
want to look that up and see but I just
know this
white guys that played a guitar win
American Idol a lot okay shout out to
white guys who play the guitar versus
versus really great singers let's move
on from American Idol because I don't I
don't have the stakes in this game
anymore all right we're done with
Americans let's get into the wedding
that I had with
a job
guys the wedding was fabulous first of
all
you know I am I guess you kind of get a
sense of kind of how I am from watching
the podcast and stuff like that and you
know I'm a you know I I [__] about
things and I you know I have strong
opinions about things and uh sometimes
I'm a little too serious about some
things you know
and I've kind of had to add you like ah
it's just a party the wedding it's just
for the wife you know it's just for the
girl it doesn't matter you know what I
mean like it's like for a guy you just
couldn't show up and whatever but I
gotta tell you it was the greatest day
of my life it really was it was like
emotional I'm I was like I cried so many
times it was seeing all my friends there
and everything it was just it really was
a magical day it like okay so we had the
rehearsal you know I'm just gonna
briefly go over it because I really want
to get Rachel on to to like go over this
but you know you know so we had the
rehearsal and it was really hot and now
we're nervous because it's outside it
was at Sterling Hills this beautiful
golf course in Camarillo it was a
beautiful setting it was like oh man
magical but it was too hot so now we
like oh my God because my mom was at the
rehearsal she couldn't stand the heat
Grandma couldn't stand the heat great
Rachel's Grandma couldn't stand he her
dad has you know some issues going on
where like that the heat was bothering
him you know what I mean and it was just
like we were like worried about that
we're gonna have to get tents and we had
these little [__] umbrellas and so
they was like oh no what's going to
happen but the next day it was like
perfect there was a breeze it was a
little overcast so the sun was blocked
but yet still bright out and nice so
that was great
and so and then even after rehearsal I
started to be like oh wow this is going
to be you know fun
um
you know and so then we uh and then the
day of the wedding came and I was like
all this preparation and planning that's
what really overwhelmed you it's all the
preparation it's all the like who's
coming where's everyone sitting are you
spelling everybody's names right you
know then like you know the venue wants
a certain number they want to know how
many people you're going to have and you
know some people aren't going to show up
but they want their money so they like
so we're trying to decide do we tell
them 95 even though it's a hundred and
we just assume five people aren't going
to show up but then if they do show up
waiting on sit it was just like all like
you're just stressing out over that and
then all the families flying in where
they gonna stay who's coming where like
you know who's going to the wedding
who's not going to the wedding uh you
know it was it was all that and then
like you know uh you know it's just a
lot of logistics kind of get in the way
of the enjoyment and the and the build
up to it right so but then when it
finally was there oh and then like two
days before the wedding Rachel tries on
her dress and she's in the other room
and then she comes in here and she's you
know I hate it because she had to have
this custom made dress by this great
designer Mike Costello and shout out to
him uh and so she was worried she kind
of designed it herself with him you know
I never saw you know she went to four
fittings four fittings and then now when
it's time to get the dress she's crying
because the dress look she don't like
what the dress looks like so I was like
I didn't want to see it on her so I said
well you want me to look at it you know
so I actually looked at the dress
beforehand and I was like if I'm being
100 I can admit this now because it's
I didn't like how it looked
when
when she showed it to me in the plastic
and everything I was like oh my God
she's not gonna like that and then she
had her mom's dress there that she fit
got fitted for her just to take some
pictures right but she was like once you
I said well maybe you could wear your
mom's dress and she's like Mom dressed
as hideous you know she was like you
know but I guess every daughter would
feel like that about her mom's dress but
her mom's dress was beautiful too right
so I'm like concerned now and she's like
so no you know I have to hit her with
the baby you could wear a potato sack
and you're gonna look good you make
everything look good but honestly she
does make everything look good her
body's designed for that kind of
designer clothes and stuff so you know I
was just saying that but at the same
time I've seen her on the runway in some
nonsense and she make it look good
listen to me nonsense that high fashion
stuff it'll make no sense to me okay and
this was just a simple white dress that
had things like I'll show it to you okay
so I'm concerned and I said to her well
you had four fittings what's going on
and then it was like she's not very
confrontational so she don't want to
like put her foot down and suffer with
me she only put her foot down with me
but she don't put her foot down with
anybody else so I encouraged her I was
like you need to hit him up this is your
wedding day you know so we did she hit
him up to the guy's credit he was like
send an address so we ubered to dress
over so they could do some finishing
touches on it and then her friend Amanda
shout out to Amanda she went and picked
it up and brought it out to Camarillo
okay and so I'm still I'm I'm concerned
to that point where I'm like damn how's
this gonna look you know what I mean
like how's this dress gonna look by the
time
um uh it's it's time to get married you
know what I mean like when she's coming
down the aisle but I gotta tell you guys
man I'm gonna show it to you she looked
awesome
okay wait come on man I'm trying to get
this one picture it's like taking
forever to render all right here we go
so
boom
and that and that angle right there
isn't even I can't even really show like
like real I'll show you other pictures
where it just like it just came out
really beautiful you know what I mean
and you know and so when I saw her
walking up with her dad
you know I started walking up with her
dad and I just was like I couldn't even
get like like by the way
anybody just getting married
um you know there's a few times the
woman wants you to cry
okay let me just give you some grown man
advice
all right actually put this up right now
real world advice from a grown ass man
okay
your woman wants you to cry when you
first see her and she's walking up in
her dress that's one of the moments that
you get overwhelmed and swell with
emotion
I was emotional it's a long walk up so I
saw her and I was just like wow but I
couldn't get like that type of emotion
because I was so amazed at how beautiful
she looked like the dress was perfect I
like I was like is that even the same
dress so I was so amazed at like how
great it turned out and just what a like
how beautiful she looked I just was like
in awe when she was walking up with her
dad you know thanks Brian for the super
chat
um I didn't even know
you know what I mean and to the point
where you're not supposed to go shake
her dad's hand and be like thank you for
your you know thank you I couldn't even
do that because I was like just you know
what I mean but that's one of the
moments she said you didn't cry later
you know what I mean but I'm just
telling y'all now like what was really
going on but I I was a blubbering idiot
during my vows
I couldn't get through those man it was
great and I went first and she headlined
you know what I mean and she crushed it
her vows were great so
you know so anyways the uh you know it
was just the kind of thing that I didn't
know I was gonna feel the all the things
that I felt like how great it was and it
really was
I just I had such
like I said I was just overwhelmed with
emotions you know what I mean it's
especially difficult
if I'm being honest
it's hard for me to watch this show
because I'm close friends with Rick and
I personally know the struggles that
Rick goes through so you guys just see
podcasts and you see all that stuff but
there's another side there's there's the
everyday life that he has to live and
it's not always easy for him
so see him and get emotional because
it's my friend I love him
so I shout out to him
because you know this is like a great
project to show how people
struggle
and I feel proud
you know because of
you know what he's doing
in his own life and to see him you know
do this
and succeed is like a really great
anyways
you know watch the show you know what I
mean I just every time I have like
frozen yogurt
I'm just kind of like this ain't ice
cream because that's all it's trying to
be like it's supposed to be like a more
healthier ice cream but I just want ice
cream when you have Frozen if you have
frozen yogurt and you've been eating it
all the time you're like oh frozen
yogurt Is My Jam when you have some ice
cream you go oh this is what this frozen
yogurt is supposed to taste like so I
don't want I don't like doing that to
myself I don't care what it is like they
always have these dumb flavors you ever
go to the yogurt place and you get the
little sample and it'll say like
strawberry [__] don't taste like
strawberry at all you know oh
boysenberry Blackberry whatever Berry
lemon lime all these different flavors
um you know peanut butter actually the
peanut butter is the only one that sort
of tastes like peanut butter I don't
know where you guys stand on that but
like
all these flavors it all tastes like
versions of yogurt okay
and then you have some ice cream and
you're like oh yeah this is what this
yogurt is trying it's like a vegan
burger man when you have vegan meat and
then you have some real meat you like
get this [__] out of my face why am
I eating this vegan meat but you know
it's like I don't care you know it's
like just stop pretending stop acting
like this this is the same thing it's
not
ice cream is way better than yogurt okay
new Pole
[Laughter]
yeah listen Rachel this is my 200th
episode and I will happy 200. yeah I I
was like the not that I didn't want you
on I'm just saying I had I was looking
to get like all these big guests I asked
all these like you know famous friends
of mine everybody was busy and stuff
then I thought to myself what is
supposed to be special and what more
what could be more special than my
beautiful
new wife so that's why you're here
sorry guys what do you mean
could have been a celebrity it could
have been someone funny
did he come across like that yeah
well he was all reliable everybody
okay well I didn't mean it like that but
I guess first of all we had we already
tried to record and a thing wasn't on
and I said it way sweeter and she was
all nice about it but because we had to
do it again it didn't have the same you
know what I mean but you know I meant it
no it it sounded the same the first time
I just like see when the cameras come on
now you want us now you want to like act
up this is your this is a podcast Rachel
right now so acting up is speaking up
see here we go
I'm just saying I didn't think that was
like a crazy response to like your intro
okay
this is yeah okay well how do you feel
for 200 episodes well I was feeling good
maybe two minutes ago
that's great you know cut to this year
and this is what we all want to talk
about slap gate
pursuit of slappiness
Here Comes midnight slaps
the Jada Smith Defender
I don't know
here we are dude
I have so many feelings about
what happened in this [__]
but oh man I don't know if I have the
sound for you guys to hear it
let me just play this if I can I don't
know if you guys will be able to hear it
or not
Jada I love you GI Jane two can't wait
to see it I
okay
that's the joke
I thought at first
that this was some written thing but I
actually think that Chris Rock just off
the cuff
he sees her bald head and it's just like
makes a quick GI Jane reference
as I look at it now to me harmless let's
go back again
[Applause]
[Laughter]
wait let's go here all right
who can't wait to see it all right GI
Jane two can't wait to see it GI Jane
two can't wait to see it all right
so you're telling me
like I've been listening to people
I've been listening to people talk about
this
I've been listening to people talking
about oh this was so vile
what
the Dude Looks over
he's poking fun at Will Smith he sees
the wife he just makes an offhanded
comment like oh she's bald GI Jane can't
wait to see it it's nothing
it's not personal
it's not attacking her doing some of
these idiots on the internet are talking
about this is the most vile thing I've
ever seen in my life I realize now as I
look at it again it's just an offhanded
thing he don't know about her history he
wasn't thinking about that he was just
making a funny joke in the moment in the
moment making a funny joke in the moment
that's it
and as you can see
Will Smith is laughing too because he
knows
and Chris Rock is even like what guys
it's just so funny he's like all right
you guys didn't like that let's move on
with our lives
they act like Chris Rock [__] in his
hand walk over to the to her and rubbed
it on her bald head yo ball [__] that's
what people are acting like
do you see how like nonsensical this is
this is nothing
that's for nothing joke nothing
it was
there's actually a thing going on the
internet right now Will Smith on The
Arsenio Hall Show making a bald joke
about somebody in the band and then he
even says people go and he goes come on
y'all it's just jokes look that up Will
Smith on Arsenio Hall making a bald joke
it's just a joke
like the way people are acting
they're acting like this guy was like oh
like he knew in his head right then and
there oh you know what she got alopecia
so now I'm gonna attack her it was a
small little throwaway thing that like
we should have moved past like this
that's what we should have done okay
right we should have moved past it like
that okay
um
Will Smith is laughing at it because he
even knows ah you're all right y'all got
your funny thing you know Jada says that
she's like uh here he go talking about
me again
I get her energy like she's the butt of
the joke when you're the butt of the
joke you get slapped a little bit it
depends on how hard you get slapped is
how we should react this was nothing
y'all this was nothing
okay
Chris Rock's reaction it's like what
that was a nice one okay so now he
thinks all right this is it let me move
on okay I'm not even gonna play any more
audio from it Chris Rock thinks he let's
move on and then now here come Will
Smith he comes up and he just slaps him
right
and then walks away
what
if we can now
after two days
look at this and think to ourselves
that's why you slapped him
wow
I mean
[Music]
foreign
you know I feel like I did it you know
what I mean I really feel like I did it
and my message to like all of you guys
out there that are like you know I don't
know what you do for a living but is it
the thing you want to do is it that um
you know is it was it your dream have
you made it your dream did you like not
attempt your dream you know like no
matter what it is
did you take a moment and you realized
ah my dream is unrealistic but I don't
even know like it's depending on your
age and like where you are in life
don't think anything is unrealistic uh
until you weigh to pros and cons you
know if you like a if you're a four
seven white white boy and you're 30
years old you're not gonna make the NBA
okay all right so I get it there are
unrealistic like crazy dreams but like
is there a moment that you should take a
moment and think about that let's see I
can't jump I'm I'm slow uh I didn't go
to college to play basketball so that's
out at least give yourself that like lay
out lay out the process for whatever
your dream might be because you still
might be able to achieve something some
things you know what I mean
so especially if you're young man you
know and I mean when I say young I mean
if you're under 30 if you're under 30
don't think you still can't accomplish
the things you want to accomplish
because there's so many different
outlets now there's so many different
ways to like go to school and learn a
profession there's so many different
like trade things you can get into
there's so many things you can get
experience at so you can get into the
field that you want to get into you know
I don't know but it's like dream big man
dream big and find a way to make it
happen at least attempt it you know
attempt it you know I mean because look
at this beautiful home man I mean like I
always we talked about this before I
remember from the last time it's like
it's good to be here I thought of this
immediately when I saw you were doing it
at home I was like well let me come do
the podcast here yeah you know what I
mean because it's just like this is you
know what I mean because this is like
it's it's great you know it's look at
this little setup too
I mean you're already killing it on your
podcast but this does feel like we're on
like a more traditional kind of I love
it I love it I just I should have
brought my arms but Guillermo over there
just waiting to like
pipe in a band every time we look over
here we're like right
Rick Glassman comes down on a [__]
yeah he's snapping a lot you know Bungie
love Rachel she's uh you know
Rachel said something so funny to me
I don't know she gonna hate me for even
talking about this
well Rachel has this thing you know she
was she so she's on her period right and
she's like do you know how to put in a
tampon and I'm like no like no I do not
and that's not something that I wanted
my mental Rolodex right and then she's
you know and did she get stubborn about
it she said well you need to know how to
do that you know what she goes what if
we have a daughter and you die and I and
she goes if she dies she goes what if I
die and you have a daughter what are you
gonna tell her I'm like well
just I don't know if any little girl
wants their father telling them how to
put in a tampon so that was my first
like pushback I was like what are you
talking about that she was adamant about
it she was like no you need to know how
to do this
I think it was just her thing I think
she just wanted me to do it so it was
the whole thing about I want you to do
it and then she goes her
her reasoning is well what if I lose my
arms
if I lose my arms you're gonna have to
do this for me and I was like
okay
and I just thought it was super adorable
that she thought I would stay with her
if she lost her arms
[__] I'm out you don't got no arms
I'm just kidding obviously I'm just
kidding all right I'm just being
facetious and that's gonna be a funny
joke on stage
but so so how long have you had the hair
how long is that how long is it is it
year years with the long hair but when I
started rapping when I was 18 or 19 on
YouTube it started getting pretty big
couple million views when I was like 19
just freestyling to Little Wayne Beats
and I had like the Bieber like Beatles
haircut I thought it was the Beatles
like I thought I was cool like the
Beatles and then Bieber came and then
everyone's like you look like Bieber you
look like Bieber and so my hair was
always sort of the thing but it was it
was never like a fashion statement I
just didn't know who I was and I didn't
know how to cut it you know like I
didn't have life experience to figure
out different ways to put it so for
certain people they thought it was like
a real statement but I was just kind of
like smoking too much weed and just like
if it grows it grows you know that was
kind of my whole time with Griffin make
sure you subscribe share hit me up on
Twitch
and I'll always be there for you yeah
yeah yeah
oh it's ripping Griffin
with the recap
[Music]
Step Up get slapped
oh yeah oh yeah
salt Black Adam
I don't have words that word with Adam
but it was good
Joy
[Music]
It's like Star
it always goes High
cause the Rocks off the Fly Guy
wakanda forever
ever and ever
really good story
like Robert more is shooting threes
like Rick Dees that movie got you on
your knees
you going Eric Griffin please
what's your STEEZ inside
rap recap
you know it's never right
that's how we do it
oh oh speak no people
[__] I can't believe their parents would
end up in the ditch
[Music]
don't ever
play
Slack
[Music]
s
give me a pound
[Music]
taking over the set
run a [__] like I'm over fat
wanna get kept
everybody thanks for watching thanks for
listening thanks for sharing Super Chat
special Sunday night
and we're doing it right
see you next week
With A New Beat
look at me [__] tapping my feet
to rap recap
[Music]
don't turn your back
put out your hand and get some doubt
get it again
[Music]
tell your friend
this is my dojo
[Music]
teaching that karate
the chat getting Bodied
of all time
[Music]
that's all he okay well sometimes when
y'all gonna uh send a beat in you got to
make sure the beat is long
it's the rap recap
here we go with the sick ass flow
now you know
I don't regular joke
check out the flow
make sure you subscribe and share
I know that you don't care
thank you
Twitter
[Music]
it ain't a hitter
I think it's a [__]
I'm about to quit her if I have to pay
eight dollars
everybody holla
that's about it
Eric Griffin is the [__] Kyrie Irving
with packs
he won't come back
you sound like he won't crack
it back
that was wax
evil was horrific
maybe it was terrific
I don't think so watch that thing so I
can't blow thanks for being here
[Music]
in your ears
glad you were here
now I gotta go Eric Griffin with that
flow
s
time
one of these fishy Beats
for the rap recap
I don't drink
cause I don't want to get clapped
wanna keep my senses
not trying to get slapped
that's how we do it
on Riften Griffin
this is Eric Griffin
no I'm ripping
about the book club
push it to the book in the tub
e
[Music]
let it stay on Netflix
that show suit for the [__]
Jenny Ortega
nothing rhymes with Ortega
that show was pretty good and another
one of the
another rap recap
so make sure you check it out
Step Up
thank you
give me some death
thanks for watching y'all
and I will see you next week